after 13 years of his government our
economy needed major surgery but like
Millions across our country this budget
leaves us stuck in the waiting room with
only a sticking plaster to hand a
country set on a path of managed decline
falling behind our competitors the sick
man of Europe once again
this was a day for ambition for bringing
us together with purpose and intent for
unlocking the pride that is in every
Community matching their belief in the
possibilities of the future but Madam
Deputy speaker after today we know the
Tory cupboard is as bare as the salad
Isle in our supermarket
[Applause]
the lettuces may be out but the turnips
are in
I hopelessly divided party caught
between a rock of Decline and a hard
place of their own economic recklessness
dressing up stagnation of stability as
their expiry date looms ever closer
and the figures published today spell it
out a year of stagnation growth
non-existent according to the IMF the
worst performing country in the G7 this
year a prediction today confirmed by the
obr and growth downgraded in years to
come this is a failure you can measure
not just in the figures but in the empty
pockets of working people right across
the country
13 years without wage growth 13 years no
better off 13 years stuck in a doom Loop
of lower growth higher taxes and broken
public proper services
[Applause]
Deputy Madam speaker our obr makes clear
today things don't look any better in
the long run a broken labor market
holding back our prospects seven million
on the NHS waiting lists ill health and
disability on the rise and the
consequences as we've just heard
deferred to the Future the classic
short-term sticking plaster cycle
decisions cynically duck today paying
for working people tomorrow
it doesn't have to be like this Britain
has enormous potential on science
innovation technology we should be
leading not lagging we need an
industrial strategy that removes
barriers to investment
of the announcements today are nowhere
near the mark the lowest investment in
the G7 that's their record
all our competitors know this they're
gearing up for An Almighty race for the
opportunities of tomorrow and we've got
to be on the start line not back in the
changing room tying our laces
now he mentioned the war in Ukraine
and of course on this side of the house
we stand with Ukraine and we stand with
the government's response to Putin's
brutality we'll look carefully at the
details of the military spending
announced and we will support them
but what we cannot accept is the use of
the war as a blanket excuse for failure
he has weak
for another countries wages in this
country are lower now in real terms than
they were 13 years ago
the average French family is a 10th
richer the average German family a fifth
richer countries which face the same
pandemic countries which face the same
War
and the war didn't ban onshore wind the
war didn't scrap our home insulation
scream team the war didn't run down our
gas storage facilities they did
decisions which hurt working people
battling the cost of living crisis right
now
it's been the same story for the whole
13 years always the sticking plaster
never The Cure and today's budget does
nothing to change that
again we see a failure to grip the
long-term challenges
while the leader of the opposition is
delivering it as well
be listening no we will now listen to
the leader of the opposition so
today's budget changes nothing again we
see a failure to grip the long-term
challenges no determination to create
growth which unlocks the potential of
the many working people being made to
pay for Tory choices and Tory mistakes
[Music]
Madam Deputy speaker these are the
organizing principles of conservative
economics judge them by their choices
the running down of our Public Services
paid for by working people the disaster
of the Tory mortgage premium paid for by
working people
opportunities still miss for a proper
windfall tax paid for by working people
that's what makes the Chancellor's boast
about lower inflation so ridiculous the
idea that it's a tax cut British people
can see through that they see their tax
burden at its highest level for 70 years
and they know it's not the government
that's lowering inflation it's working
people earning less enjoying less it's
their sacrifice that is helping to bring
inflation down and they deserve better
than another Cheap Trick from the
government of gimmicks making vampire
was trying to claim the credit
even with the price guarantee the
average Energy bill has doubled in 18
months
because of their recklessness the
average mortgage payment is up 2 000
pounds a year a a massive hit to living
standards however they cook the books
and yet still no real ambition on
Industrial strategy no real ambition on
the clean energy that will give us
cheaper bills no real ambition on house
building the same old Tory choices
sticking plaster politics no growth for
the many working people paid
and let's turn to his policies on the
cost of living Madam Deputy speaker I
say his policies because there's a
history to this a pattern over the
course of the whole cost of living
crisis time and again it's labor who
bring the government not just to its
senses but to our position
who first pushed for the energy price
guarantee labor who first called for a
proper windfall tax labor who first
stood by people on prepayment meters
labor
who first said we should freeze the
price guarantee this April labor and and
we can go on because it's also labor the
first committee to extending the fuel
Duty cup
policy that in January he dismissed as
part of a dossier that he published
so for one poor soul in their research
team at least this really is a back to
work budget
and
[Applause]
for the chancellor as he promotes this
policy in coming days
use your own car and For Heaven's Sake
make sure you know how to use a debit
card
and I look forward to the Prime Minister
promoting the swimming pools policy
unlike the car he won't have to borrow
one of those
but Madam Deputy speaker the cost of
living crisis is not over
and once again they've left money on the
table when it comes to oil and gas
companies money that could have been
better spent on working people
politics is about whose side you're on
there are loopholes that urgently need
closing even the former CEO of shell
admitted that they should be paying more
but the long-term plan just isn't there
the same old Tory choices the same three
principles sticking plaster politics no
growth for the many working people pay
and you see those principles at play in
our broken labor market
to what the chancellor said today
focused on that as well it might
the figures announced in this budget
show how damaging the current situation
is to grow a long-term drag on our
ability to create more wealth our
inactivity levels are particularly
shocking up half a million since the
pandemic the worst jobs recovery since
the G7 people unable to work because of
ill health more than ever before
now we will look at what the chancellors
announced today because on these benches
we've long called for reform of the work
capability assessment for a welfare
system that supports people with
disabilities and long-term health
conditions to thrive at work the
Universal Credit system must help people
into employment and child care is a huge
barrier to that we've made the case for
reform
but on child care of course more money
in the system is obviously a good thing
[Applause]
foreign
they obviously didn't listen to when he
said he's actually going to do it
that's up and down the country no it's
no use having more free hours if you
can't access things and it pushes the
cost for parents outside the offer
that's what we've seen before
and on pensions he made a big spending
commitment which will benefit those with
the broadest shoulders
where many people are struggling to save
into their pension
we needed a fix for doctors but the
announcement today is a huge giveaway to
some of the very wealthiest
the only permanent tax cut in the budget
is for the richest one percent how can
that possibly be a priority for this
government
[Music]
the truth is our labor market is the
cast iron example of an economy with
weak foundations our crisis in
participation simply hasn't happened
elsewhere not to this extent it's a
feature of Tory Britain and Global
excuses won't wash we need a wider
reform agenda
instead of making working people pay we
need to make work pay move on from
growth that's based on insecure low-paid
jobs to growth which comes from good
work from strong employment rights that
can deliver higher productivity growth
from the many for the many but makes
people better off in all parts of our
country
I welcome his announcement on Devolution
deals the principle that we should push
power out of Westminster is fully
supported on this side of the house it
fact we want him to go further
communities Beyond Birmingham
birminghamster deserve the right powers
and the same powers to drive growth as
well
[Music]
former Health secretary
a signed copy of his book
he knows that growth needs and NHS fit
for the future
and no country can be fit for work when
there are seven million people on
Hospital waiting
so I was waiting for him to match
Labor's ambition absolutely waiting for
him to match our plan to train more
doctors and nurses to tackle the
capacity crisis a policy he publicly
praised just 15 days before he became
Chancellor and yet it never came a
madame Deputy speaker if there was ever
a symbol of the poverty of ambition that
is it
because the reality is the country
getting sicker is a country getting
poorer and a country getting poorer is a
country getting sicker health and wealth
must go together Britain can't afford to
be the sick man of Europe Britain can't
afford the Tories
[Applause]
is another way on these benches we
understand institutions must be
respected constraints accepted that
fiscal rules should be fat sound and
followed rigorously that every pound is
precious and must not be wasted
look they want to shout about their
record let them shout wages lower taxes
higher borrowing higher debt higher
their chaos has a cost
[Applause]
certainty is vital for the growth we
need essential for businesses and
investors in our country as we've
spelled out compared with a blanket cut
to corporation tax investment allowances
are the right approach but the question
many businesses will ask today is how
long before the wind blows again and we
all go through this again
and that's what they don't understand
about business investment they're
endless fighting on tax is bad for
growth in and of itself
Adam Deputy has been real stability
means that taxes don't go up and down
like yo-yos
warranty tax credit regime doesn't get
overhauled twice in six months
yeah order okay that's enough I now
can't hear the right honorable gentleman
at all exactly and it's nothing to do
with being old not quiet
Dharma
thank you let me give an example of that
instability it's a bit of a thought
subject at the moment but when he was
culture secretary the chancellor
apparently took some lessons on the
rules of football
so let me provide a refresher the amount
of times his government has broken their
fiscal rules 11. that's one football
team the amount of times they've changed
corporation tax policy 22 that's two
teams you've got a game
but if he wants the post-max analysis
he'll have to consult the experts back
on his screens and ours this weekend I
know the whole house will want to
applaud that
but Madam Deputy speaker a budget is not
just about the choices made but the
choice is ignored Britain needs more
than certainty for growth that's the
least we should expect we need change
stability and success
anyone listening to this and worried
about NHS waiting list any about crime
it's about crime going unpunished they
don't want to hear they don't want to
hear about the waiting list
they don't want to hear about the crime
going unpunished house building rates
falling don't want to hear about that
either I suppose do you yeah
they will have heard very little that
makes them feel hopeful about our future
they could have used sensible taxation
policies or non-doms or oil and gas
companies have made the money work for
working people tackle the vested
interest that gum up our planning system
and shown real ambition or the
investment we need to turn us into a
green growth superpower
and that was the test today can we move
beyond the usual sticking plaster
Solutions set a new direction for growth
that serves the interests of working
people
but I'm afraid the verdict on this
budget is clear they won't offer change
because they can't
going backwards the sick man of Europe
once again
that's the Britain they've created and
they should look it in the eye
because today's figures on growth put
their failures up in lights
after 13 years of tourists sticking
plaster politics 13 years of no growth
for the many 13 years of being asked to
pay
working people are entitled to ask am I
any better off than I was before and
after 13 years with no excuse
nobody left
the resounding answer is no and they
know it
yeah
foreign